a wonderful book a much thumbed ladybird
book called The Story of nuclear power
it was published in 1972 and I used to
go through it again and again and I was
enthralled to read how scientists split
the atom here in the UK for the first
time and they did it at the Cavendish
Laboratories in Cambridge and I noted
that the world's first civilian nuclear
reactor the first civilian nuclear power
station was at Calder Hall in Cumbria
narcos sellerfield
and I look back at the optimism that uh
that you see on every page of that book
and I look at what has happened since
and at the the short-termism of
successive British governments and their
failure to do justice to our pioneering
nuclear history and their abject failure
to think of the needs of future
Generations above all of the families uh
that today struggling with the cost of
energy in this country and I feel like
one of those beautifully drawn
illustrations in that ladybird book of
what happens in a nuclear pile when the
graphite rods are taken out at the wrong
moment and my blood starts to boil and
steam comes out of my ears and I think
I'm going to to melt down and I ask
myself a question what happened to us
when size will open in 1966 it's with
the eighth reactor that this country had
built in just seven years why have we
never got back to that kind of Rhythm
had we lost the gumption
and dynamism of our parents and
grandparents it gets worse when size
will be fantastic white Dome was
completed in 1995 it was the fifth
reactor in seven years and I remember
1995 an era that was technologically so
primitive that people used to use things
called car phones and went down to
Blockbusters to rent VHS videos think of
the Colossal technical progress in other
areas and contrast the paralysis in
British nuclear energy how many new
nuclear power stations new nuclear power
stations have we built in the 27 years
since how many have been connected to
the grid how many slices of bread can we
toast with the additional nuclear power
we've created how many washing machine
can we power
how many families have been helped with
extra nuclear energy
the answer is none zero zilch
the French have loads of new
capacitations
already who built four more since 1995
bringing their total reactor Fleet up to
about 56. the Indians have added about
12 the Chinese have built more than 50
additional nuclear reactors since 1995.
and you know why we failed it's not even
as though we have some cultural aversion
to to nuclear power I mean I just met
those those nice protesters outside they
were it wasn't kind of atom craft nine
danker uh that there wasn't some Lefty
thing uh that they seem to be objecting
to the disruption to the pure nimbyism
out there uh it's it's if that's not
that's not the issue I will diagnose the
the problem
it's called myopia
it's called short termism
it's a chronic case of politicians not
being able to see beyond the political
cycle for 13 years the previous labor
government did absolutely nothing to
develop this country's nuclear industry
they said it didn't make economic sense
I think it even said that in their in
their manifest of all thanks a bunch
Tony and thanks a bunch Gordon tell that
to British businesses earned industries
that are now desperately short of
affordable and reliable electricity tell
that to families that are struggling
with the cost of heat and light this
winter and they're not only the they're
not the only culprits because in the
run-up to the 2010 election as you
you'll have seen famous video on YouTube
now Nick Clegg the then leader of the
liberal Democrats now some kind of tech
lobbyist in California said that the UK
shouldn't build more nuclear power
stations like sizewell C and he didn't
say it was unsafe he didn't have what he
called a theological objection he said
that the problem was
look they wouldn't even be completed no
point starting it he said because it
wouldn't even be completed until guess
when 2021 or 2022 so gee thanks Nick
and it's because of that kind of myopia
that here in the country that first
split the atom we have only 15 of our
energy uh from nuclear and our
electricity from nuclear and it is
falling whereas in France it is at 70
percent and we ask ourselves why France
is more self-reliant than ourselves when
it comes to energy why they find it
relatively easier to hold down costs yes
nuclear always looks when you begin it
always looks relatively expensive to
build and to run
but
it is certainly cheap by comparison with
hydrocarbons today
in fact
if Hinckley Point C were already running
this year
Hickory Point C were already running
this year been delayed for ages and ages
of course it'll be cutting fuel bills by
three billion pounds
I'll say that again pinkly Point C we're
running now you'll be cutting our
National Fuel bills by three billion
pounds so you have to look ahead and you
have to be aware of the false economy if
you have an old kettle that takes ages
to boil it may cost you 20 pounds to
replace it
but if you get a new one you'll save 10
pounds a year for every year on your 10
10 pounds a year every year on your
electricity bill
and I remember when the government
finally did the deal on Hinckley uh
Hinckley C in fact I think I was already
sitting in the cabinet and I remember
some people protesting then about the
about the strike price that we did 92
pounds 50 uh per megawatt hour per
kilowatt hour it was very very expensive
but it doesn't it doesn't look very
expensive today
that's why we need to pull our national
finger out and get on with sizewell C
that's why we're putting 700 million
pounds into the deal just part of the
1.7 billion pounds of government funding
available for developing a large-scale
nuclear project to final investment
stage FID in this Parliament and
in the course of the next few weeks I am
absolutely confident that it will get
over the line and we will get it over
the line because it will be absolute
Madness not to this project will
create tens of thousands of jobs but it
will also Power Six Million homes that
is roughly a fifth six million homes
roughly a fifth of all the homes in the
UK so it will help to fix the energy
needs not just of this generation but of
the next a baby born this year will be
getting energy from size World C long
long after she retires and this new
reactor is just a part of our Great
British nuclear campaign we will build a
reactor a year again we will build them
across the country at least eight of
them large ones and small modular
reactors and of course they're not the
entire solution to our energy needs far
from it yes we are increasing our own
domestic hydrocarbons we've got more gas
out of the North Sea this year than last
year considerably more 26 percent more
uh we're putting a big bet as you know
on hydrogen on carbon capture and and
storage and because of the the activism
of the gov government we're not racing
towards our Target I will we will hit it
of 50 gigawatts of offshore Wind by
2030. I think 50 gigawatts is a huge
amount that's probably half the
electricity consumption of this country
from offshore wind
I tell everybody who uh who who who
thinks hydrocarbons are the only answer
we should you know get fracky and all
that offshore wind is now the cheapest
form of electricity in this country
offshore wind is nine times cheaper
than gas I'll say it again offshore wind
is now nine times cheaper than gas
because of the insanity of what Putin
has done and that way it makes sense for
us to become more self-related of course
it's entirely clean and green so
Renewables are not only helping us to
defeat climate change they're also
helping to keep bills lower now than
they would otherwise be in this crisis
what Putin has done is to launch a kind
of Kamikaze attack on the on the world
economy
he doesn't care how much pain Russia
suffers
he believes that ultimately we will
Flinch that Western politicians don't
have the stomach for the fight he
believes that we will give up on Ukraine
give in to his aggression and go back to
mainlining his hydrocarbons and I have
to tell you he is wrong
he's wrong in his assumption about the
British people I think he's wrong in his
assumption about other European
governments too by the way I talked to
Olaf Schultz last night and it's
absolutely clear that Germany is
Resolute in moving away from dependence
on Russia and Putin in this strategy is
going to fail
so we're helping people now with the
cost of living
and of course there will be more cash to
come whoever takes over from me in the
months ahead substantial sums that's
absolutely clear but even more important
than that our British energy security
strategy
Great British nuclear is rectifying The
Chronic mistakes of the past taking the
long-term decisions that this country
needs and I would say frankly folks over
the last three years that this
government has done some pretty
difficult things and we've done some of
the hardest uh tasks that you can set uh
politicians we we fixed our relations
with the European Union we settled that
that argument uh pretty conclusively
we've got brexit done and took back
control of our lawmaking even though uh
though we knew it would not be easy we
opened up our economy postcovid faster
than any other major country because of
the speed of our our vaccine rollout we
led the whole of Europe
in helping the ukrainians and in in
standing up to Putin and seeing the
wisdom from the start in arming them and
assisting them and at every stage in the
last three years and I hope I can say
this give this one will be one of my
little one of my last speeches uh in
this office uh at every stage what we've
tried to do is put in the things that
this country will need for the long term
to try to to look at uh what future
Generations uh will need for their
prosperity their productivity and for
their quality of life and and to reduce
the cost of living as well so whether
that's gigabit Broadband gone up from
seven percent uh penetration to 70 of
premises now uh three new High-Speed
Rail lines uh investing massively in
this country's ability to make its own
uh vaccines
fixing social care coming up with a
solution for that problem I think if
you've had to say this government has
not shirked the big decisions we've
raised our eyes we've looked uh to the
Horizon and I just say whoever follows
me next week I know that they will do
the same so no more National myopia no
more short-termism let's think about the
future let's think about our kids and
our grandchildren about the Next
Generation and so I say to you with the
uh with the prophetic candor
and Clarity of one who is about to to
hand over the torch of office
I say go nuclear and go large and go
with sizewell C thank you all very much
thank you
[Applause]
right thank you all very much and listen
I'm going to take some questions from uh
our friends in the media we've got Andy
Bell from channel five I've just seen in
the in the second round
thank you very much prime minister Andy
Bell 5 News you just said that
substantial sums will be coming for
helping people with their energy bills a
lot of people will be looking at what
you've announced today and say that's
not going to help me in the short term
but you've said substantial sums will be
coming is that just wishful thinking on
your part or have you discussed it with
either the people who may be your
successor would you like to take this
opportunity to say whoever might follow
you you must go ahead and offer targeted
real help to people in the short term
with their energy bills okay thanks Andy
very much I know that you you have heard
before it is vital that people remember
that more money is coming uh anyway over
the next few weeks and uh and months so
uh by October uh you're gonna have uh
another 650 pounds going to 8 million uh
vulnerable households uh by the the
Autumn 29 million homes especially every
home in the country I will get 400
pounds to help with the costs of energy
every pensioner is going to get 300
pounds everybody that receives
disability benefit and that's about one
in 10 of us now is going to get another
150 pounds so there are chunks of money
uh that are going to keep arriving in
people's bank accounts but what is clear
from what both candidates have been
saying is that uh come uh the the the
the new Administration there is going to
be a further package that is going to be
nice and clearly we have the fiscal
Firepower uh to to sort it out and one
of the reasons for that is because in
spite of the difficulties that we've had
particularly in spite of of covid we do
have a robust uh employment situation we
have the revenues coming in to the
exchequer that will enable us uh to help
people we've got unemployment down to
about 3.8 percent uh which is you know
really pretty pretty low to talk about
the uh Britain in the 1970s it hasn't
been as low as that uh since I was a kid
and that gives us the the strength to
continue continue to to support people
but what I'm trying to say today is we
we've got to do that but we've also got
to look at the uh the medium and the
long term and that's where we failed as
a country we've got to be absolutely
brutally honest with ourselves and now
is the time not just to put in the uh
the wind and all the other Renewables
not just to do the hydrocarbons but
remember the vital importance of nuclear
in the in the base load and the the
Great British nuclear strategy uh will
take us back up to at least 25 percent
of our electricity coming from nuclear
it's got to be done and uh that's the I
I I know that the next uh uh leader over
he or she maybe will also want to uh to
deliver that as well
Camilla Turner Telegraph
we need a cover of inquiry is coming
I wasn't facing in schools and the
delays in our justice system do you
think enough attention was paid to the
trade-offs of lockdown and looking back
would you do the second lockdown again
yeah Camilla I just I just think it's
very important when people look at this
and I've I've read some of the the
commentary that's appeared in in in your
distinguished pages on this on this
matter it is very very important for
people to remember what the the measures
to restrict the transmission of kovid
we're trying to do we had at the at the
peak of the Epic of the pandemic we had
about 40 000 people uh or more in NHS
beds and the NHS has a total about a
hundred thousand beds and we knew that
if you if you had uh another twenty
thousand thirty thousand more and it
could easily have happened
mathematically uh in the NHS the system
would have been overwhelmed and what
would have happened then is that all
those cases that you've just mentioned
all those people who didn't get uh the
help that they uh wanted with their with
their cardiac uh were concerns with uh
their cancer diagnosis all those other
health conditions that you've just
described uh they would even pushed out
even further to the right and people
would have got the the NHS would have
been in an even worse position now to
deliver the help that's required so what
the government is doing instead is
mounting a massive uh campaign to to cut
the covert backlogs uh we're putting in
all the community under Community uh
diagnostic hubs uh we're investing
hugely in the NHS now to help people get
the treatment that they need I
appreciate that uh delays in in a e are
are very severe and and the ambulances
are backing up but that's why we're
funding the reforms of of social care
and that's why we're trying to help
people you know get out of the acute
sector and into the place where they can
be treated treated better but I just
come back to I think there's a sort of
inversion of logic going on people in
the night saying
too much lockdown cause the current
problems in in the NHS I'm I'm afraid to
say that the opposite is the is the case
in the sense that if we hadn't locked
down if we hadn't tried to prevent the
spread of disease then the problems
we're facing now in the NHS would be
even worse and and I I I really urge
people just to think about the the logic
of what they're of what they're saying
uh Natasha Clark the son
thank you prime minister
um I'd just love to know what your
advice might be to to the millions of
Brits are going to be struggling with
their energy bills this winter what
should they be doing should they be
turning down the heating putting on a
jumper is there anything you words of
comfort you might wish to say in your
last final moments as prime minister and
I would love to know do you have any
regrets about your time in office yeah
okay uh uh
Natasha so look on on the second thing
I'm going to I'm going to leave that uh
to to you because I'm sure
I'm sure that you won't I'm sure I mean
you know I'm sure that uh you know you
you know younger fitter more active
journalists than me can readily uncover
a couple of things that you might think
we got wrong uh if if you really if you
really if you really put your put your
minds to it uh but uh I think on the
whole I I look I'm very proud of a lot
of the things we did I think that we we
had it we we we had a some very tough
things to deal with and I think on the
whole uh the countries come through them
uh very well we have now wait to get to
your point of course uh families up and
down this country are going to face a a
very tough winter and uh we just have to
accept that and I think that what I
would say to people is that the
government really really understands the
difficulties that you are facing we we
totally get it uh I want to go back to
the the things I said to Andy about the
measures we have in place to to reassure
people that more is coming that were on
your side we're going to do everything
we can to to help but also I think what
I would like to get over to people is
the sense of of the future that is going
to be better once we become more
nationally self-reliant once we have a
British energy security strategy in
place that delivers long-term
sustainable electricity energy for our
people and that is ultimately how to fix
this problem so I think what I would say
to people is look I know it's going to
be tough and I'm sorry it's going to be
tough but once we're through it we'll be
in a much but much much better State and
the the the out of this catastrophe of
Putin's War I think a good is going to
come in that Europe will wean itself off
Russian hydrocarbons we will no longer
be subject vulnerable uh to his black
male and in this country we will have
greatly accelerated long overdue reforms
and steps to become energy independent
in particular by rectifying the the
damage we've done to our nuclear
industry
Sam Lister Express
Minister um
haven't been
taking more enthusiastically obviously
the moratorium that was a moratorium and
fracking which you seemed to soften on
recently
um and also given it is your last few
days in office
um David Cameron disappear quite quickly
and has remained a very low profile
Theresa May is an assiduous backbencher
what kind of prime ex-prime lists should
we expect you to be
Sam I mean look on the second thing I
mean I think that only time will tell is
my is my answer on that one but I look I
I my my intention uh and what I
certainly will do is give my full and
unqualified support to whoever takes
over from me and and otherwise you know
really to uh to to to get on with life
uh but on on on on on fracking you know
I'm not I'm not uh intellectually uh
morally uh opposed to this at all uh I I
think that
um if if we could if we could you know
Frac uh effectively and cheaply in this
in this country that would be that would
be a possibly a very beneficial thing
I'm just I have to say slightly dubious
that it will
um it'll prove to be the Panacea
and that that's all that's all I would
say I would much rather that we we
focused uh
on the the things where we are brilliant
uh and where the environmental damage is
is really minimal like offshore wind I
mean did I did you did you pick up just
now what can I ask you if you can
remember how much cheaper is offshore
wind than gas
nine times cheaper uh so so you know I I
I I kind of rest my case let's we are
brilliant at offshore wind uh we need to
put in sustainable
um uh base load in the form of in the
form of nuclear uh of course we need a
diversified policy and you know where
where our local communities want a
different solutions they should be
allowed to to go for different solutions
but I I I I don't think that uh that
particular solution is going to be the
Panacea that some people uh some people
suggest and you know we can be flexible
but uh we shouldn't we shouldn't put all
our eggs in that particular basket
Antonello uh Guerrera La Republica
thank you very much prime minister
um speaking about about nuclear power
how much concern are you about what is
going on around the separation
nuclear brand in Ukraine and how close
is the risk of a nuclear catastrophe and
secondly still about Ukraine as you as
you mentioned the topic in your speech
we are seeing a counter-offensive of
ukrainians starting for kirkerson do you
assume this might be realistically a
turning point to regain Crimea and other
occupied the Russian territories and
Bush and push Russia out of Ukraine
thank you very much thank you very much
Anthony look first on zapariza uh I
think it's it's very important to uh to
understand this is this is a huge plant
and it it delivers
um a large proportion of Ukraine's
electricity Supply I think it's entirely
legitimate of the Ukrainian government
to want to uh to take it back uh in as
an effective way as they can from
Russian control clearly the objective of
the of the Russians about which they're
absolutely I think explicit is they want
they want to unplug it from the uh
Ukrainian grid and plug it into the the
Russian grid and uh you know uh they're
a much greater nuclear experts than me
in this room uh I'm told that that has
that has all sorts of risks uh doing
something uh like that we don't want uh
to take any risk with zapparish I think
it's important that uh the uh that uh Mr
Mr Grossi and the iaea are allowed to
get in and do their do their their
inspection uh but I've got to tell you I
think the zaparisia is a is a Ukrainian
plant and uh and the ukrainians should
uh should have it back in their control
and and on your point about
um
uh what's happening in the south in
cursive
everybody should not minimize
punishing what they're
called the Russians from Kiev they've
driven them out of huge tracts of uh of
territory that the Russians had occupied
the Russians are making absolutely
glacial progress insofar as they're
making any progress at all they are not
winning and they are not going to win
and that is the crucial thing whatever
happens in Curson or in the donbass it's
vital that we friends of Ukraine in the
UK or in other parts of Europe stay
absolutely Rock Solid steadfast in our
support for the Ukraine so we we
shouldn't allow our uh our our support
to be in any way conditional on uh on
what happens in uh in Castle on the
obviously uh I hope and and pray that
the ukrainians are successful in what
they're doing it's their country and you
know as I've said many times I've never
seen a a clearer case of of right and
wrong they have an absolute right to
defend it and to expel the Russians from
the territories that they've occupied
Andrew Sinclair BBC East
prime minister many people will welcome
the commitment you've given to size well
today but do you accept that when it
comes to promoting nuclear and wind
there are also many people who worry
that your legacy for this part of the
country will be to completely change it
with dozens of new substations and lots
and lots of pylons cluttering up the
countryside is this the price he sanglia
has to pay well thank you Andrew and I
look I know that I I could see your
wonderful local MP Tiz coffee in the
front row who's who's you know good
enough and didn't know she's mentioned
all this to me herself uh even though
she's a strong supporter of what the
government is doing clearly uh we've got
to make sure we do this sensitively and
you know I saw the the protesters
outside I disagree with them I think
they're wrong I think that the
disruption that they're going to
experience it will be uh short and they
and it will be worth it worth it for the
country worth it think of those six
million homes
that are going to have electricity as a
result of this incredible project think
of the difference it will make to to
people in this country and and when it
comes to uh East anglia's uh position in
offshore wind it's it's formidable and
it will yes we've got to make sure that
we uh bring the cables ashore in a way
that is uh environmentally friendly and
and and already but it will drive high
wage high skilled jobs uh here in this
part of the country as well as as well
as being part of a clean green uh future
for this for this country so I would be
very surprised if the majority of people
uh actually didn't strongly support uh
this approach I you know I I appreciate
they're always going to be there's
always going to be dissent and there's
always going to be uh going to be
objectives that's the the nature of
democratic Politics as I've as I've
discovered thank you all very much thank
you thank you thank you thank you
okay so there you have it they're very
typically Boris Johnson speech for the
prime minister's final major policy
speech he was speaking there at the size
World C nuclear power station in Suffolk
let's speak to our political
correspondent Ali fortiscu so Ali what
did you make of it he said go nuclear go
large and go with sizewell c
do we have Ali
there we go hey Ali what did you make of
it
yeah it was a pretty passionately
delivered speech wasn't it by Boris
Johnson making the case for long-term
investment in green energy rather than
just short-term fixes for the cost of
living crisis he said that there's been
a chronic case of politicians not being
able to see beyond the political cycle
with his fire firmly aimed at Labor and
um Nick Clegg too for not approving
nuclear plants he gave the go-ahead to
sizewell C in Suffolk which could power
he says six million homes help with
energy for 60 years so he um clearly
wants I think two things firstly he is
in Legacy making mode and making clear
that he views green energy as something
that whoever takes over from him needs
to focus on needs to carry on with he
talked to it's worth saying about
vaccines about his record of getting
brexit done he said that this was a
government that has not shirked from big
decisions but I think also and more
importantly really this was also a
warning almost to whoever takes over
from him that his presence could well
Loom over the next prime minister and we
will know who that person is in the next
couple of days it is highly expected
that Liz trusts will take over from him
she is the likely favorite but even so
Boris Johnson still has very loyal
supporters people who didn't want to see
him gone and I think today what we've
seen is Boris Johnson making his legacy
but also showing the direction that he
would like the government to go in he
said that substantial Psalms more cash
will come on the cost of living of
course daddy is not his decision to make
he also said that only time will tell
what time what kind of previous prime
minister he will be but I suspect his
presence will be felt when he speaks
people will listen and he will Loom over
the next government whoever the next
prime minister will be yeah Ali okay
thank you so much
[Applause]
now British Charities have launched a
major appeal to raise funds for Pakistan
to help the country recover from
devastating floods that have killed more
than 1100 people and left Millions
without a home nearly 1 200 deaths have
been recorded with a third of the
country now underwater the red dots on
this map there you go or they show the
flooded areas which have now spread to
the north of Pakistan large parts of
nashera and chasada near peshawa have
been inundated
this